so check this out i'll tell you why i
think joe biden's panicking and i tell
you why i think we are inching closer
towards this
the democratic base in this country is
is absolutely insane not like the
republicans are our uh as a party are
doing much better but the democrats are
split dramatically from like moderate do
default democrats who don't really pay
attention to the fringe far left
the far left control more of the
manifesto for the democrats than the
moderates do who don't really pay
attention you can see this in the pew
research where the spike is actually
further left what does that mean
they tell joe biden we want open borders
we want total amnesty but joe biden
can't win on those positions so what
happens in office he says something like
okay we're gonna
stop trump's evil remaining mexico
policy
so now all the migrants come in it's
catch and release they get caught they
get released in the community now you
have children sleeping under bridges in
the dirt in mcallen texas because joe
biden needs to take actions the far left
wants but then can't actually deal with
the influx of migrants and migrant
children because the policy is insane it
makes no sense so what does he do
the bite administration has been
smuggling has been trafficking children
into other republican states under the
noses of the leadership of those states
and the tennessee republicans freaked
out when the whistleblower came out with
this video footage showing that they
were using i guess now there's a
whistleblower talking to tucker carlson
saying they're using the texas air force
bases to take migrant kids and traffic
them to other states because biden can't
come out and say we're turning the
children away into the desert because
that was trump's policy oh no he can't
come out and say we're going to put
these kids in the concentration camps
the democrats were complaining about for
five years although they're doing that
either anyway so he's got to shuffle it
under the rug but eventually the
republicans in these red states find out
about it the sheriff in ohio finds out
what they're doing and these states are
now
outraged the federal government is not
actually doing anything to serve the
people but is actively in a panic to
shuffle the problem under the rug while
actively refusing to solve the problem
in fact making the problem worse
you imagine biden keeps doing things
like that and you're going to see states
saying we will not comply okay okay so
that's like a good that's a lead up to
it but okay assuming that something
happens and then a state does secede
like let's just pick texas and i don't
know would it be organized would it be
six states at once would be one state
that goes first
that has a lot to do with if it would
succeed or not because if 49 states
seceded it would it would succeed if one
state tried it would probably fail
uh but what would it look like
we hereby declare we are
our sovereign countries your two left
brain on this one
it doesn't need to be a bunch of guys in
suits walking in and saying ah hereby
declare it could literally just be that
a guy in texas stops taking the phone
calls of the federal government because
he doesn't care anymore because the the
the influence of the federal government
has been weakening so a law enforcement
officer looks at his phone and it says
ice and he goes i don't even care what
were you saying sir and then over time
it just breaks apart basically they'll
take over a long period of time that
would be something like the governor
sending their own national guard to the
border in place of the federal
government as an example but like we've
seen this before under the obama
administration sheriffs were refusing
this and i think the one thing that
would actually lead to a potential civil
war is something like hyperinflation or
extended inflation because once the
money starts becoming less valuable
that's when you get people in the
streets and everybody starts panicking
but to your point about the immigration
thing this is one of the biggest
mistakes the trump administration made
throughout its entire time the reason
they were putting the kids in cages
quote unquote was because they wanted to
deter children from showing up to the
border and the trump administration as
far as i know never made the moral case
for a harsh policy on the border and we
see what happens when you're soft on
that there's kids that are being dumped
over here like i was at cpac i met guys
that went to the border and they showed
me photos of kids with disabilities that
were just literally jumped over the
fence by coyotes like they can't walk
and they're being dropped off because
obama sent i'm sorry biden
40 and slip right there sent the signal
to people i mean obama did the same
thing if you remember the unaccompanied
minor things pre uh trump but biden sent
the signal that if your kids come here
at least this is how it was translated
into latin america that if your kids
come here we'll take them which is worse
than saying if your families come here
we'll take them because now we have all
these kids going on this dangerous
journey seven thousand miles if you've
seen it they come up on these trains a
bunch of them fall off it's a disaster
you have to make the moral case for
strict enforcement and we're seeing this
across the country in not just
immigration policy but in san francisco
where they don't afford shoplifting
everything breaks down so what's
happening now florida is sending
troopers to texas to help secure the
border in south dakota saying i think
national guard
because the federal government isn't
doing it lieutenant colonel allen west
is running uh to primary greg abbott
because he says abbott is waiting on
permission from the federal government
to defend its own border and he makes a
really good point abbott needs to take a
stand
oh that was
brutal metaphorically yeah yeah also
also desantis is running for president
that's why he's sending the troopers
like let's let's be honest do you think
so a hundred percent oh okay
against trump though
i saw the cpac poll they did one with
trump and one without trump without
trump 58 yeah he's probably trying to
say hey buddy endorse me and i think
desantis would would in a lot of ways
probably be better way better because
and people are like you know oh they'll
smear him they'll attack him in the
media yeah but trump really boils
liberal blood you know desantis they're
gonna be like i don't know who that is
and i don't care you're not gonna be
able to rally people the same way well
desantis isn't gonna wake up shoot
himself in both feet and wonder why
there's blood all over the floor every
day like he's not gonna be tweeting
these disgusting horse faces yelling at
me on the internet nah he's you know
he's a bit more tactful but i will say
we've we've definitely seen some of this
under obama there was a period i i can't
remember when this was i think it may
have been under bush actually where yeah
actually i don't know maybe it was obama
we saw a wave of states asserting
sovereignty they were like declaring
that we are independent sovereign and
and retain our rights and everything and
it was like all they all started doing
it
10th amendment movement right
but i still i think that just shows the
escalation like if you a lot of people
say this all started with trump and then
so actually it started with obama
actually it started with bush well yeah
literally they're all connected there's
no like we're not in a vacuum it wasn't
like one day someone pressed like reset
on the country and then we all woke up
and said who should be the president
it's all connected going all the way
back since even probably the colonial
days yeah i think it tracks technologies
change because no longer do we have to
send a letter uh and send someone to go
ride a horse to washington dc to tell
them what i told them to tell them like
we have telephones and computers and we
can work these in this decentralized
manner the states can function in a more
we can decentralize power way easier
with modern technology and i think the
consciousness is now kind of
showing that but it's coming out as you
know secession what it's this is more of
a decentralization i'll tell you what
the problem is it's the absolutism of
the democratic party and the inability
of conservatives or should say of the
republicans and many conservatives to
assert themselves on things so i'll
explain what that means the democrats
demand absolute law so they say we
should ban these guns
and then you're like dude i live in west
virginia we've got like coyotes and
bears and stuff like come on you can't
you know i mean and also i hunt i live
in the middle of nowhere i'm not you're
not worried about this stuff you live in
a different place
it makes no sense a lot of the things
the democrats advocate for because how
it affects the other half of the country
who don't live in cities but they demand
that absolute law if if the city is
negatively impacted everyone in the
country must be must be under the same
law republicans don't come out and say
we demand x they say no wait don't
speed bumps for the democrats yeah over
a long enough period of time the
democrats keep passing laws that are
favorable for cities well probably not
even favorable for cities but designed
to be favorable or i'm sorry they're
designed to appear favorable to cities
although whether or not they actually
work i think most of the time they don't
and then rural people get negatively
impacted by it but but what percentage
of the democrats is it because i just
had the new york city democratic primary
and they elected the cop who wants to
bring back stop and frisk and the
anti-crime unit which is horribly named
because the police are all anti-crime it
should be called the anti-shooting unit
but they elected the tough on crime cop
and he won in the first round of voting
and when they did the ranked choice and
they did that he finally got over the
top maya wiley the bill de blasio woman
who literally her campaign was like i'm
a black woman vote for me i'm
progressive never did anything in her
life except serve as a counselor for
bill de blasio like she she did worse
when they ranked it up like she was the
second place which is horrible and i'm
ashamed of my city but it's the
democrats what are you gonna do but
adam's not only one but he won
uh with minorities like he got 45 to 75
of the vote in all the majority uh black
or hispanic areas that's how he won but
think about how amazing it is that he
still is he still wants to confiscate
guns he's still very much you know
except for him he can have a gun right
exactly so he very much is just
he's still a democrat and so we're like
but he is pro cop like think about that
logic where it's like well at least he
doesn't want to completely abolish the
police
he's still he's still bad on a lot of
these things but true but like giuliani
was a gun grabber as mayor of new york
city michael bloomberg was a gun grabber
and a nanny stater like he didn't want
you to have a big soda so yeah right but
i always say new york is different so
like as much as i want to say oh the
democrats are different the reason new
york city is different and you've been
to new york city is because everybody
rides the subway and everybody walks on
the streets so democrats actually have
to live with the policies that they
advocate for there they can't escape out
into the burbs that's why we get tough
on crime mayors and that's why i had
faith in new york city and i said that
this election would determine whether or
not i would consider moving or not
because we we actually do vote tough on
crime it's it's not chicago it's not
baltimore which i drove through today
and then what happens is because
they're actually not tough on crime the
extremists then protest the democrats
own policies
they go around and they constantly
obstruct the streets they protest they
new york's not a big riot place but it
never ends and then that turns into a
national movement so because people like
uh you know uh eric adams right yeah
because he's like
they call him tough on crime by new york
standards no no he's he's legit he's
like i'm going to bring back stop and
frisk like the republicans weren't like
we're going to bring back stop at first
he's like no no we're going to shake
down people right this is some skulls
that's the problem you see what happens
is then black lives matter comes out and
turns that local problem from democrats
into a national problem and then demands
everyone in the country live by this
ideology and because they have such
influence in national level
communications politics marketing and
corporations because new york is a hub
for that
some random dude in in in west virginia
who lives in the mountains next to his
you know his brother cletus who's
actually 20 miles away has to have new
laws on his guns because of the failures
of new york democrats and it's not
necessarily just er it's not like it's
eric adams fault it's that the people
who live in these cities continually
elect the same kind of people who do
very similar things with very similar
policies that don't work well i mean you
you're you're right to a certain extent
because i mean new york city distinctly
banned chokeholds but after george floyd
died from a maneuver that would have
been illegal for an nypd officer we
still cut a billion dollars out of our
police because we had to solve the
problem of minneapolis's policing issue
people in london are protesting over
jordan's floor hands up don't shoot
which michael brown didn't have his
hands up and the london police don't
carry guns
yep yeah so so what's happening is you
have this
you know ian mentioned it's technology
it's the internet's communications it's
not about any of the policy it is
literally my tribe must win at all costs
and we will demand power thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time